president biden in saudi arabia claiming
he is talking tough with the oil rich
dictators over the murder of journalist
jamal khashoggi
and laughing off questions over his
controversial fist bump with the
country's crown prince
with respect to the murder of khashoggi
i raised it at the top of the meeting
making it clear what i thought of it at
the time
and what i think of it now i said very
straightforwardly for an american
president to be silent on an issue of
human rights is this consistent with
inconsistent with who we are and who i
am he basically said that he uh he was
not personally responsible for it i
indicated i thought he was yes you're
coming under a lot of fire for your fist
bump with the crown prince
i just want to give you a chance to
respond to that but also how can you be
sure that another incident another
murder like jamal khashoggi won't happen
again well god love you what a silly
question how could i possibly be sure of
any of that
the president is under enormous pressure
to bring down surging gas prices with
the trip with democrats in his own party
getting tired of his inflation spin i
think
that we have a responsibility in
leadership to be honest with people to
not try to spin them and then we have a
responsibility to chart the way forward
it doesn't mean that there's a silver
bullet on fixing inflation i want to be
just straight about that and then i want
to say here's the plan here's the path
but was it all for nothing
at least one report indicates biden will
be coming back home with no announcement
on producing more oil but have no
worries while he might not get any more
oil he is making moves on green energy
saudi arabia will also partner with us
on a far-reaching clean energy
initiative focused on green hydrogen
solar
carbon capture nuclear and other
projects to sell to accelerate the
world's clean energy transition
and to help the u.s clean energy
industry set global standards when we
see the impact of this visit
i suspect you won't see that for another
couple weeks
and we'll see more when we see gas
stations start to lower their price
consistent with their pain for the oil
so i'll start with you uh geraldo the
president has done everything he can to
trash the saudis uh and to destroy
american energy independence and so he
goes over there hat in hand uh to ask
for more oil and instead of delivering
the goods there was no announcement that
we're getting more oil what he does is
he announces that we're going to be
partners with saudi arabia on green
energy what is wrong with this man i
think it's it's a discordant note to say
the least i i don't understand why he
went there why he had to go there
knowing that he's being criticized for
emphasizing electric vehicles and so
forth at a time when gas prices are
going through the roof i will say to the
president's uh in his defense gas prices
have been trending down a couple of
pennies every day
and it's been every day for almost the
last month now and to me the biggest
thing about this visit to saudi arabia
came right in the last hour or two
the announcement that uh there was this
deal between saudi arabia and israel
where israeli planes can now land in
saudi arabia and vice versa this is a
huge deal saudi arabia of course is the
keystone of the anti-israeli arab bloc
and
if we can get normalized relations
between saudi arabia and israel i think
that is a huge huge step these islands
in the red sea i know them sailed past
them a lot of tension over the years
between egypt saudi arabia and israel
that looks like it's going to be in the
past right now it does seem to me that
there is meaningful progress not on the
energy front ironically maybe bitterly
ironically because we need it but on the
political front whereby saudi arabia now
joining many other the arab states in
normalizing relations with israel all
right the abraham accords going on yeah
so we don't really give biden credit for
this do we i mean biden didn't do this
the guy can barely get over there and
you know decide whether he's going to
shake his hand or fist bump so as for
the fist bump i'll go to you tyrus
what's with the fist bump i don't know i
guess if a handshake or a fist bump
somehow just because you pull the
fingers back it's different but the same
it's laughable i also like the fact that
he said um
i don't believe him but he told me he
didn't do it so you know and then i i
said i think he didn't do it and the
only thing they said they'll partner
with us
with clean energy when is that going to
be
because right now we we got enough
partnering with green energy when are we
going to see some actual stuff that was
the longest speech about nothing
and
the fist pump was probably more on the
other side the prince was like i don't
want to shake this guy's hand i'll
acknowledge him okay bruce
yeah there you go
and there was no they didn't come out
together with a great announcement there
was nothing he just came back and he
said basically everything that he was
going to do he didn't really do but stay
tuned yeah well it it looked like a
perfunctory fist bump but but aside from
it one time or one knuckle yeah but
what i lawrence what's interesting is
that you shook your head when i said it
seems like he's trying to take credit
for work that's been done by other
presidents yeah i mean it's the same
thing the trump administration had
already set the stage for these
negotiations other countries that
already signed in obviously he didn't
get a second term and so those
negotiations were already put in intact
it's the same thing that he does when it
comes to the vaccine he takes credit for
it he didn't help get it done if biden
was in office it would be the same
bureaucratic system but there's a lot of
stuff to deal with right here at this
press conference i take you back to the
trump years doing
uh when russia meddled in our election
and everybody was hyping up this first
visit with donald trump when he was
supposed to meet vladimir putin now it's
important to know also that president
trump had already started to put
sanctions record sanctions right on the
russian so he gets there and he looks at
putin in the eye and he says
just don't meddle in our elections
anymore now this is after he's actually
taken action joe biden goes and they
hype this meeting up he says that he
confronts him about jamal khashoggi then
he fist bumps to god
i mean there's there's really no action
being taken the family is criticizing
him for this i'm just saying the media
went crazy over that incident yet
they're pretty silent when it comes to
this but there's so much happening
domestically here when it comes to
inflation you see the party abandoning
him right now you see the democratic
strategist they don't want to be
involved with him you hear back channel
talk from the obamas they're talking
about but they're not upset about the
job that he's doing they're upset that
they're losing and their narrative of
identity politics and the spin and they
thought roe v wade was going to be a
killer issue for them and it's just
simply not working but we should have
expected this from joe biden he stayed
in the basement for the majority of time
i don't understand why the media is
upset he's doing exactly what he said he
was going to do if this was any other
industry it would have been considered
malpractice what's happening in this
country
it is the media's job to be the watchdog
of the american people when it comes to
these politicians it's not like a lawyer
where you have a board a bar to
investigate you it's not like a doctor
to have a state board to investigate
teachers anything the watchdog is
depressed and biden is doing exactly
what he said he was going to do we're
just being harmed in the process you
know what uh the the the idea that even
the democrats don't believe a word that
this president says and yet as lawrence
says they won't criticize him they don't
criticize him when trump was president
every day he's a liar he's a liar he's a
liar he's a liar yeah well first i think
you know the questions from the press
corps are never really on behalf of the
american people who want answers about
when their lives are going to get better
and when things are going to cost less
for them um but the headline that
president biden didn't walk away from
this meeting with any kind of new
agreement to pump more oil he has no
intention of significantly lowering gas
prices because they are intentioned or
they have an intention to transition the
country away from fossil fuels onto what
they think is going to be this new
alternative energy utopia and so they
can't lower gas prices because that
would that would ruin that that agenda
where they say well if gas is too high
then you should be buying an electric
car at the same time they're pushing
that agenda including in saudi arabia
you have california telling people who
own teslas or other electric vehicles
not to plug in during peak hours because
they may have blackouts and brownouts
you have people in
the dutch protesting because the
government is infringing on their
personal property rights to push this
green agenda and you also have europe
essentially you know turning their coal
plants back on they're in an emergency
crisis when it comes to natural gas
because of what russia has done in
ukraine so the the alternative energy
agenda is a very painful one but the
pain is the point from this
administration they have no intention of
reducing prices for americans at the
pump and in terms of democrats now
coming to terms right before an election
about how things are too expensive
convenient about inflation well they did
this this is their fault not a
republicans did not vote for the
american rescue plan which shot
inflation through the roof okay that was
all democrats and the problem with
inflation is you can't put it back so
well you know voters are looking at it
and saying who did this
and they're looking right at the
democrats well it's just like the
president's saying you know we're going
to have a little pain you know but we
want democracy in ukraine uh and as a
result your gas prices will go up hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else